[Music]  with the tasty app you can now plan your  meals ahead of time by shopping multiple  recipes at once we've created curated  picks of your favorite tasty recipes and  made them shoppable with walmart's  online grocery pickup and delivery  service browse from hand-picked meals  fun party spreads and full weeknight  dinners choose the one that's right for  you you can look over each recipe  watch its videos  and review its ingredients  [Music]  then select your favorites to make  and add them to your grocery bag with  just one tap  your bag has all your ingredients  organized by recipe you can even see  what ingredients your recipes share so  you don't buy any unnecessary extras  when everything looks good tap to  purchase your items through walmart  grocery where you can schedule and pick  up curbside at your nearest walmart  [Music]